Quantum supremacy’s that moment when a quantum
computer beats the best supercomputers at
solving some kind of problem, and it’s a
very exciting time right now in quantum computing
because, as of recording this video we’re
on the brink of having quantum supremacy,
maybe it’s already happened.
So I’m going to explain what quantum supremacy
is and why it is so exciting.
So to explain quantum supremacy it’s worth
me explaining how quantum computers work.
Us physicists, we call normal computers ‘classical’
computers, and classical computers work with
binary.
There’s loads of bits that can either be
in a state of zero or one.
In a quantum computer you have quantum bits,
qubits, which can be in the state zero, or
one, or they can be in a special intermediate
state and that’s called a superposition.
It’s a special phenomenon in quantum physics
that quantum computers take advantage of.
Now when you measure a qubit the result you
get is based on a probability, so if you set
this superposition state to be in the middle,
you’ve got a 50% chance of getting a zero
and a 50% chance of getting a one.
But you can tune that state so you can make
it so that you are more likely to get a zero
than a one, or the other way around.
So that’s the first phenomenon of quantum
physics that quantum computers take advantage
of.
The second one is called entanglement, and
this is where you bring together several qubits
and you join them together, and now that whole
thing has to be treated as one object.
So if you take two qubits and you join them
together, now this object can be in the mixed
state of four states, so zero zero, zero one,
one zero and one one.
Each time you add a new qubit, you double
the number of states that this thing can be
in, and that goes up exponentially.
So if you want to search through a whole load
of different states, a classical computer
has to search through them one by one.
But in a quantum computer you’ve got these
special quantum algorithms where you can enhance
the probability of the state that you want,
and diminish the probability of it giving
you back the state that you don’t want.
So those two phenomena: entanglement and superposition
are what give quantum computers their power.
So, what kind of quantum computers exist in
the world today?
There are a whole bunch of different companies
trying to make a quantum computer: Google,
Intel, IBM, Microsoft, D-Wave, amongst others.
And to complicate matters, there’s not just
one kind of quantum computer there’s actually
a whole load of different approaches.
I’ve broken them all down here.
An important thing to point out here are Universal
quantum computers.
Universal quantum computing can theoretically
simulate any quantum system and so it’s
the fundamental computing machinery of the
Universe.
There’s other approaches that aren’t Universal
like quantum annealing and ion trap systems.
What they’re focused on are solving certain
nice problems better than classical computers
by taking advantage of quantum physics and
they’re a valid approach if those kinds
of problems are valuable.
They can be used as a good stepping stone
towards a Universal quantum computer, because
Universal quantum computers are very difficult
to build, and it’s good to learn stuff along
the way.
I’ve also included the number of qubits
in these quantum computers as of today.
Now qubit number is just one measure of how
good a quantum computer is.
Just as important is how low the noise is
in the qubits, so how high quality the qubits
are, and also how well the qubits are connected
together.
So let me describe a bit more about how you’d
do the experiment to prove quantum supremacy.
Actually measuring when it has happened is
quite a difficult thing to do.
So you take your best quantum computer and
you take your best super computer and you
need to give them a problem to solve and then
compare the results.
And to begin with the quantum computers can’t
do anything better than a supercomputer except
for one thing, and that’s be a quantum computer.
Which might sound absurd, but the logic is
this.
You can simulate a quantum computer on a classical
computer, but it gets more and more difficult
to do so the more qubits you have.
Now IBM has got the current record for simulating
a quantum computer with 56 qubits, so people
are seeing this as the target, that if you
build a quantum computer with more than 56
qubits, you can’t simulate that with a classical
computer, and so the quantum computer can
do some thing better than what a classical
computer can do.
So the problem that they are looking at showing
that the quantum computer can beat a classical
at is a certain problem called a sampling
problem.
Now if you remember back when I was talking
about a qubit being in a superposition state
between zero and one that gives you the probability
of which one you’ll get back.
Imagine if you’ve got fifty qubits and they
are all entangled together, they are simultaneously
in about quadrillion states, that’s a million
billion states at the same time.
But when you measure that computer it just
gives you back one state which will just be
a bit string of zero, zero, one, zero, one,
one, one, corresponding to each qubit.
Now if you keep measuring that computer over
and over again, you’ll get different bit
strings back, so different states back, but
over time you’ll build up a distribution
of those states, the more likely ones and
the less likely ones, and that’s a probability
distribution.
And each time you measure the quantum computer
that’s like taking one sample from that
probability distribution.
Now quantum computers do that completely naturally,
whereas simulating that whole thing on a classical
computer is incredibly difficult.
So that’s the problem that they are looking
at proving that a quantum computer can do
it better than a classical computer.
So what’s that problem good for?
Absolutely nothing.
To begin with.
I mean there’s some crossover between this
kind of sampling problem and a sampling problem
you get in machine learning.
But the shapes of those problems in quantum
computing and machine learning are very ver
different, but they come from the same sort
of underlying physics which is called statistical
mechanics so there is a tentative overlap
there which people like Google are very very
interested in.
But I don’t undersell this achievement because,
if you think about it, classical computers
have been around for seventy years and they’ve
had literally trillions of dollars worth of
money pumped into research and development
to reach them to the incredibly sophisticated
machine they are now.
Quantum computers have been around for twenty
years-ish, and have had say a hundred million,
maybe a billion dollars worth of investment,
for that technology, this new novel technology
to come along and beat the classical computers
at even one narrow thing is a, is a huge achievement
and that’s only going to progress in the
future and I’m really excited to see how
that whole thing evolves.
And finally I just want to end with a fact
which I think is incredible.
You know I said that you can simulate, using
our best supercomputers, you can simulate
a quantum computer with fifty six qubits.
Now if you raise the number of qubits up to
two hundred and sixty, the size of the computer
you’d need to simulate that would need more
bits then there are atoms in the entire known
Universe, which I think is just absolutely
bonkers, but I love it.
Thanks so much for watching, that’s all
I’ve got for you today.
And thanks also to the sponsor of this video
brilliant.org they’re a website where you
learn by doing.
And I don’t know about you, when I was at
University I would sit down, I’d write down
all the lecture notes, but the time where
I’d really learn the subject was when I
sat down and did problems and Brilliant do
a great job of making this fun and slightly
addictive, they have a way of framing questions
that I get slightly obsessed with trying to
work out the answer to.
But that makes it really fun.
And they cover a bunch of different subjects:
physics, mathematics, computer science and
many more.
So if you are interested in checking that
out go to brilliant.org/dos the link’s also
in the description below, and otherwise, thank
you for watching again, and I’ll see you
on the next video.